Often said to be a silver
lining in a down market.
When your investments go south,
you can sell them from
your brokerage account
at a loss
and then use that loss
to reduce your tax bill.
In the US, once your losses
exceed capital gains,
you can subtract up
And if your losses exceed $3,000,
that can be carried forward
to offset gains in future years.
That's some damage control for portfolios
in a bruising year in which both
stocks and bonds have declined.
could even make the crypto
crash a little less painful.
Crypto investors have collectively
lost trillions of dollars
since digital coins peaked, but they
may have a special tax advantage.
Stock owners have to follow
what's called the wash-sale rule.
If they sell a stock for a loss,
they have to wait 30 days before
buying the same security again, or else
it won't be eligible for a deduction.
So far, the IRS has not said this
wash-sale rule applies to digital assets.
Still, some tax experts
warn crypto investors
could get burned
by the IRS'
economic substance doctrine.
That rule basically says that
And if you plan on selling crypto
at a loss, make sure you know
how long you've been holding your coins.
Anything under the one-year mark
is considered a short-term capital loss.
Short-term losses
will be used to offset
short-term gains first
and then long-term gains.
Whilst this strategy won't completely
ease the sting of crypto losses,
it may provide some relief.
Happy harvesting.